all right let's flip it over to the game
that and i'm gonna be fully transparent
i've got my notes i watch chief's
chargers all the way until like eight
minutes left in the third quarter don't
spoil it for me but i've seen enough
to
uh come to some
very important conclusions as it relates
to the la chargers yeah as it relates to
the decision to make justin herbert the
quarterback from oregon the guy we met
in indianapolis before the world turned
upside down and we were impressed with
him when we had a chance to sit down
with him i'm far more impressed by what
i saw
in two and a half quarters of action
this guy has it right and i don't know
what the hell anthony lin is thinking
now maybe he's just being respectful to
tyrod taylor now we know that there was
a a bad painkilling injection that
created the chest pains that sent to the
hospital and maybe they just don't want
to take the guy's job away from him at
this point i don't know how anyone can
watch what justin herbert did on sunday
and not conclude that he's both the
future and the present for the la
charter uh i mean i i'm with you there
mike i am i mean if i was them i would
be i would start the new era i really
would you can play the style of football
anthony lin wants to play with justin
erbert yeah he made an interception he
was
his bad his bad play of the day
it was a what was it a second and two he
could have ran for the first down and he
tried to throw the ball across his body
down the field that was stupid there's
no doubt about it 17-9 but you also like
okay that was stupid he made some throws
in that pla and plays in that game that
you know tyrod taylor and a lot of
quarterbacks in football aren't going to
make so you have to take that into
account too they were up at that point
because of some of those plays first off
mike i mean aren't you amazed by his
like just his look on the field
to me the first thing that jumps out is
i turn it on i go other than cam newton
is there a bigger quarterback on the
field right now than justin herbert he's
got great size and we saw what he can do
when he runs and punish people uh i
thought that was the first thing that
jumped out let alone his ability to
really throw and make game-changing type
throws
it is such a jarring combination this
giant with a fresh face with not quite
doe-eyed right because the moment wasn't
too big for him but all of a sudden this
sport that we're accustomed to watching
we know the names we know the faces and
here's this new guy who gets thrust into
the mix without warning literally i mean
he found out minutes before kickoff he
was going to be playing and he has it
you can just tell and that's one of the
reasons we missed the preseason this
year you don't get the chance to see who
passes the eyeball test and who doesn't
well here's justin herbert in his home
opener no fans there but regardless
there wouldn't have been many chargers
fans anywhere relative anyway relative
to the chiefs fans he's got it he can
move and he can throw he had a touchdown
run he found a gear
good luck catching him when he finds
that gear when he turns the corner and
heads to the end zone he's going to be a
weapon that way he's clearly a weapon in
the passing game some of the throws he
made he had a 39-yard pass to mike
williams the tyrant matthew made a great
play on in the first half that thing was
as you would say a freaking laser lazy
it was incredible incredible and he had
more he had other throws like that he
had throws that connected and it didn't
connect there there was one where he
tried to fit one into keenan allen in
the third quarter down the middle nobody
nobody else makes that throw no maybe
patrick mahomes i agree and he and he
put it there right right that was an
eye-popping throw i know the throw
you're talking about keenan allen down
the middle and he's got like two or
three guys around him to where you go
oh
like is he really gonna throw this i i
see that the guy's a little open but
this is dicey and it was on the money
and you're right i came away saying the
same thing like a few of these throws
these are only like your top tier nfl
arm type throws even the touchdown pass
in the back left corner you know that's
unbelievable a laser right the corner's
in a position where he's trying to look
at the the guy inside and outside
because he's going wait the back of the
end zone's behind me there's not that
much room for this guy to just throw
some missile by me and i think he did
the pace of the ball shocked him right i
mean he's amazing yes amazing so that's
what arm can do and you're right i mean
if i'm the chargers
i know anthony lin wants to go with
tyrod taylor but man i just got to think
there's got to be a deeper conversation
about the better
move for the future of the organization
and everything about it
one of the things that keeps me focused
on watching the condensed games because
i really have to fight because there's
always a distraction i can always see is
there a new story that i need to cover
did somebody text me it's very hard for
me to remain focused one of the things
that helps me keep my focus i'm always
watching for something unusual that's my
challenge right look for something that
stands out for example there was a
fourth on one play in the second quarter
the the right guard of the chargers
clearly left early and it was missed you
just you're wired to watch for things
like that right uh they converted by the
way and they went down to get a field
goal there was a moment and i think it
was that same drive second and three
from the 19 the chiefs 19. austin eckler
has a nice little run he breaks it free
he gets down toward the and at the end
of the play here comes justin herbert
barreling into the action not recklessly
almost like a guy following his shot in
basketball like that presence of mind
like this play is still going on there's
something i may be able to do it's the
old right place right time it reminds me
of how tony dungy explained to frank
o'hara's mindset that led to the
immaculate reception because tony dungey
wasn't playing for the steelers when the
immaculate reception happened when tony
dungy got to pittsburgh he said
i'm not surprised by the fact he made
that play because in practice he's
always hustling to the ball he's always
trying to make something happen and this
is the reality you can have 99.999
percent of the time where you do that
and nobody notices no gain there's no
benefit that one time though that
something screwy happens and you're
there that's a play for the ages yeah so
just the fact that in the guy's first
game when he had no chance to even think
about it he's he's showing that kind of
hustle and not every quarterback should
because you're putting yourself in arm's
way he didn't get hit or anything that
was the moment to me they said this the
we can say all the things we want about
the arm about the legs about the body
but this guy's got a mentality that is
going to serve him very well over the
next 15 or 20 years they have their guy
yeah and the sooner they admit it the
better off they're going to be yeah i
agree with you there too i do and and
you're you know
i think what you're explaining is a guy
that you look at and you know yeah he's
a quarterback and i see he's got big
time but he's a football player he
really is he's just got a feel for
what needs to be done in the game and
just hustling and like you're talking
about running after the ball oh maybe
the ball falls on the ground maybe the
guy breaks a tackle and i can you know
nudge somebody out of the way and spring
them for a bigger run you know that's
what football players do and uh yeah the
kid's got incredible talent an
incredibly high ceiling he really does
he could be a superstar with the skill
set he has and you can see he's got the
poise too he's he wasn't like flustered
at all at any moment in that football
game he was always calm cool and collect
and yeah some of the things he did
especially in the first half were pretty
damn special hey and at the end of the
half they didn't have a whole lot of
time they had a couple of timeouts he
was poised and confident and he
conducted a two-minute drive that put
them in position even with a couple of
penalties in the end they had a hook and
lateral play that that came that close
to popping for a touchdown right if if
keenan allen makes the flip more
accurately to austin eckler that's a
touchdown to end the half and uh oh boy
i don't know that the chiefs can close
that margin let's flip it over now
and i didn't again i i ran out of time
at about eight minutes left in the third
quarter and and the chiefs offense had
not done much by then no
why did it take so long for them to wake
up and then what finally happened well
okay so here's the the first thing is
it's this defensive scheme
this defensive scheme
really gives the kansas city chiefs
issues i mean we've known
last year mexico city against the
chargers they struggled offensively
right
um they've lost to the seattle seahawks
two years ago up in seattle
they they've they lost to the chargers
two years ago in a thursday night game
they've played this scheme even in the
super bowl down 20 to 10. i mean it
wasn't a pretty day we know they made
the plays to win the game but there was
a lot of moments of going damn i don't
know this they're in trouble they can't
seem to find a big player expose this
defensive scheme it gives them issues
and the chargers have the right formula
not only is the scheme you know allow
them to drop seven but they have the
front four to where they don't ever have
to blitz they never have to blitz they
rarely blitzed in the football game
itself and then because of bosa
ingram and jerry tillery
who was wow right establishing himself
as one of the better interior pass
rushers in football here already and i
saw him in person for a few years at
notre dame he's the real deal
that is the first advantage they have to
harass that chief's offense
i you know i'm not up on my full history
of interior pass rushers who went to
notre dame but there is one who turned
out to be pretty damn good and his name
was alan page and it's too early to
start making those comparisons but he
did block an extra point which was one
of paige's extra things on top of
everything else he did but that that's
the one thing i noticed in the first
half and you know von miller told us at
the super bowl how the challenge with
defending patrick mahomes is he just
keeps fading back and back and back
there was a lot of fading back and back
and back because it was bosa it was
ingram it was tillery
busting through and putting the heat on
him forcing him to drop back and
ultimately forcing him to throw to
someone who wasn't there yeah and and
you know really the bottom line and one
of the things i said on my podcast
yesterday when i do my deep dive of you
know games and stuff and this is one of
the games i watched on film
they don't win this game if it isn't for
patrick mahomes legs he won the game
because of his running it was nothing to
do his arm we know it's special but
first touchdown drive two big scrambles
that really were the biggest plays of
that drive to get them down there to
score the touchdown
third and 20 21 yard scramble helps them
get what the game tying field goal at
that time oh break the pocket to the
right full on the run laser 50 yard like
nobody else in football even attempts to
throw it oh bam on the money to tyrekil
touchdown here we go chiefs like if his
movement isn't the way it is in that
game and his ability to do that they're
not going to be able to do anything on
the offensive side of the ball again
this goes back to our conversation where
i'm a little surprised
the chiefs
have to study some other offenses who
have had success against this defensive
scheme you know the teams i think about
right off the bat are are the patriots
and and mcdaniels because they played
the seahawks and the falcons in the
super bowl they know what it takes
shanahan's had success against the
scheme itself but they don't have enough
plays that expose the scheme and enough
underneath stuff that's really the big
thing and i was surprised by that
because it was the issue last year and
they kind of answered the bell but you
take away the big plays kansas city
again showed that they will struggle uh
with just executing and moving the ball
consistently when you do that
yeah it's uh it's something to see and
it's going to be you know we're trying
to figure out where the rivalries are
going to be who are the teams that are
going to contend with the chiefs do we
just hand the next six super bowls to
them i don't know that we can hand the
next six division titles to them not
with justin herbert i want to circle
back to that chargers have something and
here's what anthony lynn now needs to
worry about
he he'd better make it happen with
herbert because
you're going to have other guys out
there
looking at their options around the nfl
and they're going to eyeball the
opportunity to hitch their wagon to
justin herbert oh yes and lynn's going
to have to worry about guys working
behind the scenes trying to convince the
chargers to make a change trying to get
the chargers to hire him here's how i'd
make your team better you know a lot of
crap that happens off the grid anthony
lynn's gonna have to worry about that if
he doesn't get the most out of justin
herbert and one way to get the most out
of him is to get him on the field and
and i i looked it up it was two years
ago to the day that
tyrod taylor got injured in that
thursday night game i thought so against
the jets two years to the day and got
bounced for baker mayfield well let me
tell you what we saw from justin herbert
on sunday was a hell of a lot better
than what we saw from baker mayfield
that thursday night this should be a
no-brainer i understand out of respect
to tyrod taylor you don't want to tell
him he's lost his job on the day that
that you know he had to go to the
hospital because he had chest pains but
this should be a no-brainer and this is
the kind of thing where i think if they
have any difficulty if they put taylor
back under center you're going to start
having the uprising in the locker room
all right we'll agree yeah you're going
to have the you're going to have
everything you're going to have the fans
and the media just going why aren't we
playing herbert we don't have any fans
well you're right i know but they will
they will if they play justin herbert
he certainly will help that out and then
the other thing just you know the
reality of the situation you know two
things and i want to get your take on
this i mean first off
you know you said it are they being like
this extra more with saying tyrod's
gonna come back because it sounds like
it was a charger inflicted like issue
right like oh we gave you a shot in the
rib or something like that don't sue
so
us
you're the ones that aggravated it my
fault yep you're still starting but
i would just think like
this is the week to do it right now for
justin herbert you got the carolina
panthers coming to town without
christian mccaffrey
this is a defense that we've seen people
can move the ball on carolina and
with no christian mccaffrey no that's a
huge part of their offense that'll be
missing it can set itself up for you to
win this football game
and
yes let your young rookie quarterback
get important reps build some confidence
and and who knows i mean gosh we've seen
a lot of rookie quarterbacks
uh
make their teams better challenge for
playoff spots here in the recent you
know nfl era to where
i don't think it's crazy and he i think
he can play the ball control defensive
style take care of the ball type of
football i think he's capable of that
and after that game against the panthers
here's where it gets extremely
compelling because it's chargers at 43
year old hashtag tommy followed by
chargers at 41 year old drew brees yeah
what a contrast if just justin herbert
comes in and look i'm telling you the
kids got it and it's amazing to see joe
burrows got it justin herbert's got it
chances are tuatanga by low it doesn't
because usually one of them
i hope hopefully all three have it yeah
right but two out of three taken in the
top six for 2020
past the test seal of approval they are
the guys now the question is what does
the team do around them and for the
charges the question is are they going
to recognize this is the guy and are
they going to keep the ball in the hands
of justin herbert and let him keep
getting better and let him be exciting
and let him lead the team and and you
know they got to be thinking about next
year and you know by next year herbert's
going to be the guy when the fans come
back right but i'm more excited about
the chargers right now than i am about
the rams yeah yeah i i understand that i
mean i i get it he's he's got
you know
you saw enough in that game to go well
wait this guy could be one of those guys
that just every week we go oh that's
special whoa you know like we do a
little bit with josh allen and the
mahomes and those kind of guys where you
just go
man oh i i've never seen anybody do that
or i can't believe he made that play
and and they have offensive talent
around them out of the fact like
in in week one and this is what i always
worry about ty rod taylor
you know the ability to make plays in
the pass game throwing the ball down the
field doing that stuff i think it's far
greater
likelihood that they can accomplish more
explosive past plays in the past game
with justin herbert i think he already
proved that and then just that game that
okay he can do things and he has an
aggressive frame of mind that's just a
little different than tyrod and it gives
guys like mike williams and keenan allen
you know a more dangerous edge to them
now because oh wait they can go down the
field and strike us that way
um but i don't know mike maybe maybe
that tampa bay new orleans part of the
schedule is what's making anthony lynn
hesitant maybe he sees that and goes
wait i don't know if i want my rookie
with those two games this is where maybe
i just need a tie rod taylor they do a
lot of different things on defense but
yeah i don't know he just he just stared
down patrick mahomes i know and a
defensive topic over time right exactly
right no i no look you get
i got a ton of respect for anthony lynn
i don't know what he's thinking if he
doesn't go with justin herbert this
coming weekend and and if he doesn't uh
he he's he's he's taken a risk uh that
that i don't think he should be taking
because he's he's been given a gift by
the football gods and justin herbert and
he only has to recognize
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports